das phoenix tagesgespräch heute mit
johann saathoff er ist der russland
koordinator der bundesregierung und ich
begrüße ihnen sehr herzlich in norden in
niedersachsen guten morgen herr saat auf
was erwarten sie sich von dem treffen
joe biden wladimir putin heute nun
zunächst erst mal ein gutes signal dass
die beiden sich treffen und das bleibt
mir tut ihnen die einer dieser beiden
eingenommen hat und die beiden in genf
zusammenkommen denn es gibt reichlich
themen miteinander zu besprechen und die
themen haben sie gerade in ihrem
einspieler schon genannt also vor allen
dingen abrüstungs themen aber auch
fragen der menschenrechte und fragen wo
wir eigentlich gemeinsame zukünftige
interessen haben die wir gemeinsam
angehen wollen wenn wir von den
menschenrechten sprechen das ja so ein
beliebtes deutsches thema das auch immer
sehr stark nach vorne geschoben wird als
demokratischer rechtsstaat wo könnte man
wladimir putin da abholen auf
diplomatischem weg nun ich denke das
wird ein thema sein
joe biden ansprechen wird auch zu recht
ansprechend wir denn wir haben einige
dinge im menschenrechtsbereich die
gerade im magen liegen
es sind zum teil auch verstöße gegen
internationale vereinbarungen die von
der russischen seite dann auch begangen
worden sind
gegen internationale vereinbarungen für
die russland eigentlich selber
eingestand und von daher ist dieses
gespräch sicher auch ein gutes signal
genau das noch mal zu adressieren ich
würde mir allerdings wünschen dass wir
nicht nur über die konflikte in diesem
termin sprechen sondern dass darüber die
herausforderung der zukunft und über die
gemeinsamen interessen der zukauf
gesprochen wird was wäre das vor allem
aus ihrer sicht aus meiner sicht ist das
vor allen dingen der kampf gegen die
klimakrise weder in den usa noch in
russland noch im restlichen restliche
teil der welt hat man interesse daran
dass die die temperatur
durchschnittstemperatur ansteigen wird
das meeresspiegel ansteigen wird
das ist auch in russland ein echtes
thema also dadurch dass irmer fonds
bilden
auftauchen ist reihenweise infrastruktur
gefährdet und deswegen bin ich sehr
überzeugt davon dass es gut wäre wenn
die beiden präsidenten mit anderen da
sich genau mit dem thema
auseinandersetzen und gucken wie man die
jeweiligen nationen auch stellt im
karten gegen die klimakrise
sie sind ja auch der russland
koordinator der bundesregierung wie
läuft das eigentlich dann im vorfeld von
solchen us russland treffen gibt da auch
die bundesregierung ein hinweis oder
einen impuls an joe biden und läuft das
völlig autonom nebeneinander
meine aufgabe ist es die
zivilgesellschaftliche zusammenarbeit
ruinieren also möglichst alles unterhalb
dessen was auf regierungsebene gemacht
wird denn das verhältnis zwischen zwei
ländern ist mehr als nur das verhältnis
der regierung zu es ist letzten endes
das verhältnis der menschen zu ändern da
ich bin übernächste woche in kaluga sich
gebhard mannschafts konferenz ich glaube
dass wir in diesen schwierigen zeiten
die wir auch im fall ist in deutschland
im ausland
gerade haben auf gespräche ankommt auch
auf gespräche unterhalt des
diplomatischen levels es gibt tausende
von freundschaften hunderttausende von
freundschaften menschen die sich
begegnen wollen und menschen die
gemeinsamen interessen identifiziert
haben um miteinander unsere beiden
länder in frieden voranbringen wollen
das finde ich wichtig was sie sagen ja
sagt auch dass sie auf diesen vielen
tausend kanälen unterhalb des
ausschließlich hoch diplomatischen und
präsidialen kanals sprechen es gibt alte
tradition zwischen deutschland und
russland gibt jahrhunderte alte
handelswege
man darf sich also nicht nur auf die
gegenwart oder auch gut gegen böse
fokussieren was sind das vor allen
dingen diese dinge die ihnen hoffnung
geben
also ich kann das nur bestätigen was ich
sagen ich würde noch hinzufügen wollten
dass russland natürlich zu europa gehört
und auch einen enormen anteil hat an der
europäischen geschichte und an der
europäischen kultur das wirkt oftmals
gerade in zeiten das schwierig ist nicht
wirklich gesehen und auch nicht
meine hoffnung ist dass es wirklich
gelingt auch dinge zu identifizieren mit
denen wir in gemeinsamkeiten und sind
wir können können und darüber hinaus
dann aus der vertraulichen
zusammenarbeit über diese dinge andere
dinge auch miteinander besprechen die
einfach besprochen werden müssten willy
brandt und egon bahr hätten gesagt sagen
wir durch handeln ich würde sagen wandel
durch handel kommen das wäre nämlich
auch meine frage wandel durch handel 2.0
auf welchen industrien könnte das
passieren
traditionell ist das verhältnis zwischen
deutschland und russland ja auch
rohstoffressourcen ausgelegt über die
zeit das muss aber nicht so bleiben
aber auch dieses verhältnis wird sich
verändern also wenn es bisher um erdgas
geht zwischen amerika und russland um
rohöl geht dann ist das rohöl oder das
erdgas der zukunft wasserstoff
wasserstoff aus erneuerbaren quellen und
die potenziale für erneuerbare energie
gegen russland einfach auf der hand es
sind riesige potenzial dort vorhanden
sind
die entscheidung dafür müssen allerdings
jetzt getroffen werden weil in 30 jahren
wollen wir spätestens klimaneutral sein
und das ist aus meiner sicht potenzial
mit dem man gut anfangen kann wieder in
vernünftige gespräche zu kommen und
darüber hinaus vielleicht
abrüstungsvereinbarungen zu finden
darüber hinaus auch menschenrechtsthemen
nochmal zu adressieren und darüber
hinaus eine freie zivilgesellschaft zu
adressieren weil die überlebens immer
demokratie auch das meint johann
saathoff und ist mit einem plädoyer hier
auf phoenix vorhanden
mit den vielen banden in der
zivilgesellschaft wie in der politik und
handel 2.0 ich danke für dieses gespräch
in einen schönen tag im norden danke
danke sehr